right now I just love that Alexander
Payne Jim Taylor team that's doing you
know they did sideways and they did
about schmidt and I've read those
scripts to me read so authentic and are
so well done and I have definite writer
envy but in the past I've read you know
like I read the William Goldman scripts
All the President's Men and Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid which are
flawless and then but I grew up a liking
popcorn movies so I haven't read all of
the scripts but the lethal weapons and
the diehards and those movies that I
grew up with in the 80s that took the
genre which could have been so you know
silly movies but did them really well
those those are the other ones that i
really admire
you